touchy mache middle-class famous tour
update kippy uh-oh we got a couple
alerts going out straighten them out a
little bit yeah guys so uh we're coming
to seattle and portland unfortunately
seattle is sold out so if you want
tickets you're gonna have to come see us
in portland then we're going to kansas
city springfield st louis nashville in
the philadelphia that show sold out
already three months ahead of time we
added a second show tickets are on sale
right now then we're going up to
providence rhode island that's gonna
sell out in boston this is low ticket
alert so get those tickets now we'd love
to see you do it welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is ru garbage little show we sit down
with your favorite comedians and we find
that they grow to be classy yeah or
they're just a big old piece of trash
i'm your host h foley coming at you on a
beautiful day we're down here at aunt
toddy's basement she's upstairs trying
to make a little extra money selling
water ice okay out of her trunk all
right it's melted but it still tastes
pretty good my co-host is coming at you
from right next to me unamused this week
he is the ceo of are you garbage bit of
international businessman he's the
prince of park avenue but always the
king of the boards baby give it up for
mr neptune 2005 kj kevin james ryan you
got some good feedback on that last time
hey what's up everybody thanks for
tuning in as always please make sure you
rate view subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube as you know those
numbers are true it's cooking coming up
on a hundred thousand baby subscribe now
uh then obviously the greatest website
of all time www.patreon.com
check it out get bonus content behind
the [ __ ] we do live streams whole
nine yards bunch of videos check it the
[ __ ] out it's a good time having a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good he works the ones and twos
he crosses the t's he dots the eyes give
it up for t-bone mcmuffin toby mcmullen
everybody what's up dudes what's up
t-bone dude shout out to red bank new
jersey and the fact that we will never
have to pay for a tire change again yeah
there's a lot of blue collar workers in
that crowd last night
shout out to jersey couple of
but gang we couldn't be more excited to
have our incredibly and i mean
incredibly special guest here with us
today for the first time kid's a bit of
a wild card i'll tell you that right now
he's certified bonkos by the way he is a
very funny stand-up comedian actor in
podcaster you might have seen him in but
not limited to we got deadbeat alone
together barely famous to comedian
starring mr billy crystal the sixth lead
undateable 36 episodes at cha-ching
that's what we're talking about
the outdoorsman a feudal and stupid
gesture which i [ __ ] love that
[ __ ] movie like i [ __ ] love that
movie i saw the documentary and then i
watched the movie you guys [ __ ]
knocked it out of the park you also seen
him in nobody's today the daily show
riffing with griffin wtf the voice at
midnight and he's one of the stars of
the new amazon original series as we see
it and of course the host of the amazing
podcast take your shoes off but the big
question with his mind today is he
garbage he's crazy i know he's a little
backed up i can tell you that right now
because he told us
give it up for rick glassman everybody
let's go
let's go i told you off camera
backed up
plea packed
oh man no i haven't i haven't um taken a
[ __ ] since i was on the voice
but we have a good time over here
buddy thank you so much for coming and
sitting down with us this is great give
us the scoop what's the back story you
said you were from cleveland take it
from there give us the origin story sure
i'm from cleveland
boy my arm's tired
it's kid's wild
how's that why i don't know i
it's all part of the dance yeah i'll
give it to you all right thank god i was
there
i'm in cleveland ohio i'm doing my thing
right
do i have a learning disability sure but
we all did well
everyone in cleveland does diagnose with
that okay it's in the water
oh there's some there's some there are
some problems with the water yeah well
there were yeah in lake erie okay there
was some problems in the water all right
what was that i didn't i mean i don't
know you got a squirrel he's probably
lying i agree it's crazy look up like
eerie water problems i don't like you
demanding me to look
they really zig when they're supposed to
zig and i'm not used to that i'm trying
to get a fact check i could treat it
like hostile oh yeah like eerie there
was uh you know those like uh caught on
fire
oh [ __ ] that's right yeah yeah it's
caught on fire but it still tastes good
it's a smoky flavor that brings you back
no you said something you said some uh
some some water ice that tastes good at
the beginning i didn't quite get that
water ice water rice is italian ice a
traditional food frozen frozen italian
nice yes yeah nothing wrong with that no
it's good stuff
um so i just what do i i'll tell you
from i'll tell you yeah mom yeah from
siblings
right
well i got my parents they're doing
their thing right they're out there
doing this dad's in the restaurant biz
oh nice okay well he was i'm this is
we're talking i'm a kid okay what what
what what what is the restaurant shout
out to flo and eddie's no longer around
was your dad eddie of flow and eddie no
he he he named it flowned his because he
liked the way it sounded i do like the
way it sounds
i'm steve from flow and eddies
uh steve now is with could we push in
marshall right gallery i'll send you
guys a commercial there you go yeah
mandatory and um
yeah he was in the restaurant biz didn't
uh uh he would get home because he
managed three of them so he would get
home at two three in the morning he had
three flowing eddies three of them damn
all right
what kind of food sports bar and grill
all right yeah okay did great it was
really good time yeah great great
restaurant would uh go in the rib uh rib
cookouts all the time and my dad was
friends with bill and beer you guys
basketball fans of course sure so
through land beer they would bring some
of the pistons isaiah thomas came jordan
came once all right not to the
restaurant but to the rib cook-off like
it was like a cool okay um
and uh people love the cornbread boy
they love the cornbread that's where we
ate we would go all the time because my
dad he would get home at three in the
morning he would take me to school at
eight in the morning always at the
restaurant so we would go there for all
our meals okay and it was great then
something happened i don't know maybe i
shouldn't talk about it
come on talk about it i don't know maybe
it's not really it's not do it give the
people what they want my dad had to get
out of the business
i poisoned scottie pippen all right what
do you want from me
you know that's yeah you're the flu game
yeah i'm just gonna say that
bad piece of cornbread over and flowing
eddie's
it was an inside job i heard almost
killed all the supersonics
you know that cornbread is world famous
and you could actually get it at the
greyhound in highland park or glendale
my brother's in the restaurant biz now
we'll get to that okay get to it yeah
but he brought the flow and eddie's
cornbread over and
if you guys ever come i'd love to take
you for some cornbread dude i'm a huge
cornbread fan are you oh my god out of
scale
one to four hundred and three i would
say four hundred yeah love it the
[ __ ] love big fan big fan of the corn
muffin the cornbread the corn cakes that
[ __ ] thomas does that you slide into
the toaster they're already in two
seconds i'm telling you they're
fantastic there's something about a new
york voice that just really works for me
and it's real right that's a real thing
or is this a character it's f it's a
hybrid he's british
hello
i'm all [ __ ] up i was born in upstate
pennsylvania so they have a little bit
of like a buffalo
disability
yeah yeah the water's on fire up there
all the time and then a little bit of
philly and a little bit of new york is
all mixed in yeah but that's neither
here nor there this show isn't about me
it's about you my friend well we wanted
to talk about the restaurant biz but uh
more than i meant to um uh i'm just like
without being pinpointed where it was i
guess i could tell you who would cook
for you at the restaurant that's what
you would go there for like freddy
freddy what ready so you would just
order off the menu out order off the
menu okay yeah i would order off the
menu and brothers say you have one
brother an older brother one older
brother so is you how much older is it
two and a half years today actually oh
happy birthday
very nice no i'm saying today's two and
a half years
oh okay yeah that's wild yeah how long
does that come right how often does that
fall once a year once a year yeah right
right i think during the restaurant he
was like four years older
that's a wacky place cleveland
so we had some issues with it
okay what'd your mom do
my mom uh sold perfume really yeah out
of the house no no no
macy's counter or whatever yeah macy's
oh really she worked at the i like wait
she had all of them or was she like a
rep she wrapped she's worked with
different fragrances during the career
of fragrance stuff so she never worked
for the macy's she worked at the macy's
at the dillards right she would go she's
one of those people that would be like
excuse me would you like to okay nice
good i'll tell you this man you walk
into a mall or a department store when
you get to that perfume section and the
ac is cranking and the ladies are all
running around oh it's a [ __ ] it feels
really good in there really see i never
like it's a little invasive yeah oh i
like it it reminds me of my grandmom
real clown i didn't get along
she zigged a lot i should have zagged
it's your fault yeah i know it always is
all right your dad's over my
grandparents your dad's
tough break for you loser that sucks
what happened
with what she died what do you mean what
happened she's an old broad
she'd be like 104 now so i was i i was
in sale my mom sells uh perfume poison
i [ __ ] i i have a very sensitive to
lights and smells and tastes okay
pictures and
it's it's just and she just just
it's poison it's everywhere she brought
her homework with her her work home well
i mean she's spraying stuff it's just in
the air yeah the man watching her it was
a lot of my personality came from
watching my mom do it because i would do
it too during summer she's confusing
people no she's so my mom she could move
some merch she's just an unbelievable
sales woman but with the best intention
like in anything not even
transactionally like she's the type of
person any time you want to get a flight
changed
mom will get it changed not you don't
have to pay a change fee you'll get the
free upgrade she's just always
schmoozing she's always schmoozing she's
always good let me see and she's looking
at the women's arms and no no no and
like the type of lotion she's like
rubbing it in gotcha not even
necessarily trying to sell it she just
loves to make friends talk with people
you know it's great i like that my dad's
a salesman but the other end my dad's
like uh my dad wants to get the sale
he's not gonna lie to you anybody
yeah
he's gonna lie to you
and um hey you can get corporate
anywhere i'll tell you that right now
but i'm floating eddie's top of the line
all right this stuff sells itself i
don't got to sell you
where'd you go to high school private
public well that's where it gets a
little confusing because i have to swear
it gets confused i ended up having to go
to a couple schools graduated from flown
eddie's i had to go to i had to go to a
few schools boys
okay um i uh in eighth grade i was uh i
was in just the standard you know
learning disability class whatever that
is just like this okay you know you're
in like this class with the people that
are like playing with balls and stuff
sure
and i still i don't know because i'm
remembering stuff so i'm sure there was
i there's more information that i don't
have but i got degraded down to the
sub-learning disability class i don't
know what that means i'm sure it was
called something else just crazy you
seem like a super smart guy thanks man
you'll look smart too thanks yeah
i've never tried a rubik's cube i would
love for you to mix it up see if i can
do it
it takes him an hour yeah
dead air makes it up for me so um
so i went into this class and and uh um
they started like tracking me i didn't
realize this at the time but they were
like they would take everyone's in that
class they note of what their everything
they're doing not necessarily bad but
ever going to the bathroom left his desk
like just a full report this is in a
regular public school yeah okay yes
eighth grade um
and
whatever happened i got to the point to
where i wasn't going to classes anymore
like i was in this for one class and
then i went to my other classes okay and
then i was in it for
multiple classes and it got to the point
where i'm only in this in that room in
this room with four other people okay
also listen uh uh i'm i'm not you know
we're all imperfect especially we're in
eighth grade
hyper kid but um someone tells you not
to they they i was at a desk and they
put blue tape around the desk so
you can't leave the blue tape when
someone tells you you're not going to
believe the balloon on the floor
where the [ __ ] did you go to school it
sounds like a zoo what are you well this
cl there's there's something this sounds
illegal it sounds like sleepers yeah
dude
you're in some kind of [ __ ]
government experiment i i really don't
i'm talking about him not you
well i didn't help my situation by you
can't you can't walk out of the blue box
so you can't set your foot out of the
box oh i'm on my knees
you know i'm crawling around it and and
they're writing all these things down
and and um i used to do remember i don't
know if you guys did this it was huge by
lake erie you would take a a pin a push
pin and uh you would put it through here
i was just thinking about it the other
day through the skin yeah the dead skin
and like you know
right yeah um so i would do that i did
that a few times and i later later that
year found out that there was reports
that i'm i'm stabbing myself oh come on
that's right somebody was looking for
his funding yeah i'm paying that right
now i was that was that was a scheme
yeah they were trying to get some money
out of the [ __ ] governor they put
this kid in a box and cut us a check
will you
i think you zoom out far enough it's a
classic case of misunderstanding a
hundred percent it sounds like and me
who lacked a lot of awareness um didn't
pick up on any of this
not to mention
people aren't speaking you directly
they're having the reports of sending it
to the higher ups and just well we
better put rick in a box now you know
what are your parents saying for all
this well this they're busy come on no
this one no my mind is to the dads and
the weeds it's [ __ ] happy hour
[ __ ] order up dude
they had to pay their bills
i know [ __ ] estee lauder was all over
[ __ ] the back you know my mom was a
big advocate i'd actually love to get
her on the phone see if i could tell you
what she said okay
um my mom would go in there and just
um
this is an a5g first
i hope he just doesn't he just asks like
how her day is and stuff oh i got to see
first yeah
is this a good time
drama of eighth grade
probably selling something
hello
hello hi mama i haven't had a podcast so
don't say anything racist okay
okay i'll try really hard hey your son's
crazy
do you have any blue tape left okay so
we're talking about eighth grade and
being put in we can't say the name but
the class and the and uh and the the in
the boxes and the rick stabs himself and
the burns with cigarettes i'll get into
that if we need to left that out and and
they're like well what did your parents
do and i was saying mom's a big advocate
would you tell what did you do because i
wasn't there what did you do you went in
and you spoke to the principal or
superintendent or something
well i i i've done lots of things but
one of the things i did was i had a
meeting and i had the superintendent
and the principal
and the vice principal and the counselor
and the [ __ ] disgusting
educational teachers that are giving you
a hard time
and the counselors and i had them all
and i went in there very calmly and i
just said
um that they were the evil evilest
people and that um they didn't know what
they were doing and then i said they
should change the name of this school
from
to auschwitz
concentration camp it is the killer of
children spirits and souls
and that they're all um should be
ashamed of themselves for taking the
school all right all right i love you
let me know i love the voice
i love you mama but wait a minute one
more thing i had i called out each one
of them one of them was himmler one of
them was gearing and by the time i got
to your teacher i called her hitler
wonderful i love you so much and mom
remember if
if this is tough for you and you need
somebody to talk to head on over to
betterhelp.com
all right love you bye
okay
it sounds like you were [ __ ] with that
that's [ __ ] insane um your mom's 100
right yeah and i didn't know this was
even happen like my i didn't know my mom
went i found all this stuff after the
fact and also okay who knows what you
remember when you remember and what
perspective you're from uh tough acting
tinactin you hip to it yeah yeah my hip
yeah you spray it upside down it comes
out and air comes out i used to do that
and a little circle would come on your
hand
and then it disappears like it's like
freeze yeah yeah it doesn't hurt you
know it's like frost um but i did that
and one day i had a little mark on it
and that later i found out that they
were saying i burned myself with
cigarettes never smoked a cigarette to
this day um but like a lot of this stuff
so now i'm in this school uh you guys
had this over here right you there's the
i said no the dc trip everyone goes to
dc yeah we got canceled because of 9 11.
but sure
oh how old are you
thirty two five
nine eleven that was in two thousand uh
eighth or ninth grade
um
i think you've been lying to me
i think you've been lying to him i don't
know whose show is this
show your mom on the phone i hope that
was an actor on the phone too
um
so i didn't get to go on the dc trip i
was real embarrassed um people would say
why can't you go and i was embarrassed i
didn't even know what i was doing i'm
like i just i'm not i'm not going to go
mm-hmm um
uh while they were introducing me into
other cl like out of other classes i was
still in this one class and i remember
that uh i was in there was a group
and like you know we the teachers are
talking everyone's in groups so it's
like a little bit more of a free-for-all
everyone's talking you're getting up
you're doing your thing and i don't
remember if i asked permission but i
went to the bathroom
and i remember coming back from the
bathroom and just panic ricky's on the
loose
i still i have my friend david still
sometimes says to me ricky's on the
loose and i was so embarrassed we met
him on the loose i went to take a piss
on the loose on the loose is a bad term
to be thrown around also i don't have
friends i'm not victimized what is that
what is this social
where are you at socially in all of this
i didn't have friends outside of school
or no i didn't really have uh you know i
wasn't i wasn't bullied no one was mean
to me i didn't even realize like just
looking back i really lacked a lot of
awareness as a kid everyone was not nice
i'm sure
there are bullies in school that are
like tv show bullies but i never really
experienced that in high school people
how you doing oh it's not you know i
can't play today people always make
excuses i always took it at face value i
thought i had a bunch of friends you
know but i wasn't ever included in
things
but then when that happened
i was really like
for the first time kind of wanting to
not
not not be that person well not not that
i want to not be included but i wanted
to like i'll
don't talk to me don't invite me um
don't don't see me right now okay you
know don't see me
um
and then uh ninth grade is coming up and
i'm now i can't i'm i have a decision
high school i'm now gonna be in this box
or i could choose to go to if i want to
go right to regular classes i have to go
to the special school it's called pep
positive education program shout out to
pat we'll put their handle up here
and uh this was uh this was a school man
this is like
pardon pardon my uh uh uh if i'm
stigmatizing this poorly but through the
eyes of of this
jewish magic the gathering playing
wanting to have friends kind of silly
boy it felt like oh these are bad kids
okay um
there was in each class as a teacher
assistant teacher and a restrainer
literally in the hallways people are
being held down on the ground kids
jumped out the window first floor like
to run away pulling them through the
window like that's getting loose kids
would seriously out the windows getting
loose that's getting loose steve got
loose yeah he's out he's getting loose
instead of zigging or zach yeah
he probably was zigging and zagging
through that field blue tape all over
um but it was also it was the first time
where i uh
i started to feel like
i had i i'm not an idiot good um
because they didn't have books past
pre-algebra
and
i
was always good at math and people
needed help and i knew everything and
the teachers saw me doing something like
why don't you help out i just remember
feeling wow i feel really good about
myself okay when i'm you want me to help
somebody else yeah um
and then i started to feel like i'm
smart well not stupid right okay uh my
brother's a brilliant boy was on
jeopardy recently one what get the [ __ ]
very smart guy you should try the
cornbread holy [ __ ] um but he was always
smart that was every one of his answers
on jeopardy charlie cornbread yeah it
was it was uh it was a southern it was a
southern theme
southern foods to start with c
uh that wasn't good enough edit that out
and um
uh it's also where i no just keep it and
put it in twice
edit it in
let's talk about movement movement baby
as you know in a tiny apartment a couple
of college dropouts teamed up to create
a watch company that turned the game
upside down a couple of rule breakers in
here you got unexpected colors clean
designs movement
is one of the fastest growing watch
brands out there right now they shipped
to over 160 countries and they passed
the savings right on the yellow yeah uh
now moving
has expanded into blue light glasses
that protect your eyes from your screens
they have minimalist jewelry and more
style style essentials that don't break
the bank all designed out of their
california headquarters because they're
all good old local boys you know what i
mean
um you get a beautiful watch ship right
to your door for free and if you don't
love it you can ship it right back for
free as well the
movement watches has the look and
quality of a 400 to 500 watch that you'd
be paying for the department store but
at a fraction of the cost of the price
because they were built online and they
own their own process from start to
finish there you go i got the ever
scroll blue light blocking light
filtering glasses that my lady uses when
she's
tapping away at the keys over there
there you go uh but if you want to
elevate your look
uh with style that doesn't break the
bank then join movement and get 15 off
today with free shipping and free
returns by going to mvmt.com
garbage again one more time that's
mvmt.com
garbage do it let's talk about ladder
let's talk about the tender moments that
you have with your family okay and if
something happens to you you don't want
to leave them in the lurch you want to
screw them you don't want to screw them
over they're sitting there holding the
bag while you're off there in permanent
dreamland
you're laying in a wheelbarrow next to
the garage
so do yourself a favor get on ladder get
yourself a little term life no doctors
no needles no nothing you do it all
online you sign up yeah why not pay a
little bit each month to protect the
loved ones you got you know what i mean
ladder is 100 digital no doctors no
needles no paperwork when you apply for
3 million in coverage or less just
answer a few questions about your health
in an application need a couple minutes
on the phone or a laptop to apply ladder
smart algorithms work in real time so
you choose to find out if you're
instantly approved no hidden fees uh you
can cancel any time you get a full
refund if you change your mind in the
first 30 days because there good peeps
over there you know what i mean finally
since life insurance costs more as you
age now's the time to cross it off your
lift because you ain't getting any
younger out there that's right you're
not you're no spring chicken anymore new
gotta get those affairs in order so go
to lotterlife.com garbage today to see
if you're instantly approved that's
ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com garbage
ladderlife.com garbage do it now back to
that job back to the show that's where i
found out basketball started playing
basketball okay uh just because that's
because you're a tall drink of water
yeah how tall are you 6'3 today there
you go
um and basketball changed my life boys
basketball changed my life okay um
because then i i graduated from pep okay
i remember that is that like high school
like high school yeah a lot of times you
go to it's a school that's where you go
usually a lot of times i don't know
usually but it seemed like many of the
people that went there that's where they
went to school okay um maybe some of
them left maybe some stayed gotcha um
but it went that i went and then i did a
good good job so then i started doing
half days i was going uh first half i
was at pep and then i took a bus back to
my school okay people like where were
you and i was so embarrassed that's
tough yeah so embarrassing enough to
explain i got my ear pierced
there you go yeah is that way that's
what you told me i was at the mall was
it the piercing pagoda no i said i got
my ear repairs it took six months
no no no it takes three hours every
morning it was a hoop i don't know what
to tell you no i got my ear pierced i
just remember like like oh i should get
my ear pierced i don't know i'm going
back to school i need to show up
different yeah
i'll get my ear pierced um
uh
and um
then when i graduated from pep they
invited me back they're like you did
such a good job you should show people
uh i play the piano like will you you
come and do a performance okay and i was
like yeah sure
it wasn't a performing school i'm just
kind of remembering that i went back and
there was like an auditorium for like
some of the people that like didn't beat
people up for two weeks they got to
leave or something and i played titanic
on the piano and there was a choir
that's saying but we never rehearsed i
don't know them they don't know me all
right it's like kind of playing titanic
if they're singing and then they gave me
a pen
if you guys don't beat anybody up for
two weeks
but when i went back to school uh uh i
saw some kids i did not know who's
coming next in that sentence
i hope he's making it all up because he
is he's a [ __ ] genius uh how's this
for for am i am i giving too many
specifics no are we feeling all right
i'm loving this it's great exactly what
the show is um yeah uh so uh i go back
to school and uh i'm in the gym and some
of my the kids that i was friends with
in like third fourth grade you know like
you they're always your friends but
you're not sure anymore but you know you
know you know timmy pretty well great
basketball player and when the gym is
like do you play basketball and i had
been playing basketball i didn't know
much of basketball i would wear um what
grade are you in at this point i'm now
back in the second half of ninth grade
okay second half yeah um and by the way
people who play basketball have been
playing basketball like they didn't
start playing in ninth grade they've
been playing
you know aau and sure
and uh
we're also a very good basketball school
okay uh we played against lebron it's
very cool okay we get to that we do but
i say that to say like it's a good
basketball program so i gotcha i don't
understand it's only scrubs yeah these
are people that play these are ballers
as i call them i would wear uh i call
them that yeah okay yeah
i think that's cool yeah
i would wear my uh
khakis i always wear cargo khakis um and
i would have the why you were playing
this is just what i wear to school okay
cargo khakis and extra large button
downs okay and uh i'm like oh i need to
have shorts so i would uh i would either
wear shorts under my khakis and just
really uncomfortable or i for a little
bit i had those khakis where you could
unzip you remember those yeah
all right yeah those are all right try
zipping them back though thanks mom get
her on the phone after lebron dunked on
you
who's seen the bottom half of my
i feel like that was anti-semitic the
voice choice
has anybody seen the um
no it's my nerd voice yeah that's what
i'm saying no you're making that
connection not me
am i more nerdy than jewish yeah i'd say
it's a 50 50 split
to be honest with you
mix up that rubik's cube
um so when tim's like do you play ball
i'm like yeah because i've been playing
not really like in the driveway or
whatever like at school
that's what god
like that was almost like if you were in
prison you go out into the house you're
in the yard yeah
you got to play
and uh i still have because
uh i would play with the teachers and
they would wear rings still and i got
hit with by accident just playing with
the ring and i had this this mark on my
face and i remember i was at pep i
didn't even know if i was going back to
school but i still like i want to be in
the yearbook if i go back to school and
i'm not in the yearbook i don't want
people to be like why are you not in the
yearbook sure so i went and i took the
picture but i was like black eye and cut
and it's like you know i was imprisoned
really add in the persona
but um so i'm like yeah i placed it like
great well
we played these guys played um and and
for me it was more like something to do
in a way to connect so i would stay
after school and start playing ball with
these guys
um
and
i made the team jv team in tenth grade
because okay shout out to ship collins
by the way he
he saw that i wanted to be on the team
you know like if he were gonna cut
anybody he cuts me
but he didn't got you i didn't play much
how tall are you at this point are you
like 62 maybe at least okay but i never
i don't know anything sure you know i
don't play i never didn't grow up with
this and i remember we didn't even have
an away jersey for me uh so i would
still go in the games but of course i'm
not getting in the way games i'm just
sitting on the benches in my
you know my
car goes
khakis in a blazer
um wearing a full basketball uniform
underneath all that stuff for some
reason i didn't realize it at the time
but this was the first time i'm like
wait i think i had some friends i'm part
of something yeah and i cared very much
and i i worked so hard i played so much
constantly going into 10th uh 10th grade
i'm on the jv teams i'm not very good
but i just i work so so so hard um and i
got decent okay and um
i have friends now i for the first time
i think this is so heartwarming
seriously yeah yeah what do you mean yes
sports [ __ ] rule dude if you're if
you're unaware this is a gripping story
uh sports do rule uh kobe bryant uh i
don't remember what interview it was uh
talked about something about how
important sports sports are not even at
the level that he was at but sure he did
he was at one of the highest levels he
did
kobe bryant yeah
and um he talked about how important it
is to at a younger age to to work with
people to get something and also
and he's like because it matters so much
because you're whatever level you're at
you you need to win you want to win and
you don't and it breaks your heart and
then you realize but then there's next
year and you try it again and you're
like losing sucks and it shouldn't
motivate you but it's just a thing yeah
and how important it is to lose not just
for sports but just like to recognize
the importance of how you feel in this
moment is chemical and matters and it's
just this moment right
um
and i'm actually feeling myself this i i
want to get merchant says my eyes are
watering but like sometimes my eyes
start to water when i say stuff like no
that's good
but um
i have friends i'm i'm i have a sense of
confidence people
are asking me before i don't think we
were on but before i was talking to you
about how like sometimes it's
uncomfortable you ask people to come to
your podcast yourself out there yeah
it's like i'm okay with it but that's
all i ever did i would be like hey do
you want to come over and like i can't i
remember i think i talked about this
recently one of my pods but remember uh
my buddy who i am friends with now but
he never wanted to play and he always
said that he's not allowed um my mom
won't let me so i i said because my
mom's such a good saleswoman i asked my
mom to talk to his mom and my mom would
call his mom and she his mom had a lie
to my mom
that's like [ __ ] dork
why wouldn't they come over and play
i don't know
yeah
i mean yeah i'm not judging i'm just
saying as a as a ninth grader look at
you know they're going like ah that's
unfortunately and it sucks as you get
older you have perspective yeah of life
so shitty some things were i don't know
if this was particularly with david but
some things were like people come over i
would get like i love competition
basketball is great because i love being
physical i love competition uh i get
aggressive in play
and we used to like friends would come
over sometimes and they wouldn't want to
anymore but like i would always want to
wrestle
all right okay
watch the 18 something
so i had an older brother at the time he
was i think i think at this time it was
two and a half years older and
he was really into boxing and his
friends would come over they would box
boxing gloves in the basement
and like two feral cats
i would stay over i would stay over all
the perfume and [ __ ] cleveland
jesus all of your activities take place
at sing-sing it sounds like
oh my god oh you got me i love it you
got me i [ __ ] love it yeah i was
annoying um i bother people i also
didn't pick up on stuff
um i always i still i've developed a lot
of tools i came into some awareness five
years ago that really changed my life
but uh i
i really couldn't pick up on stuff
unless unless you said rick i don't like
it when you do this then i would maybe
be like maybe he doesn't like this okay
you know at most but if you were just
like uh okay i'd be like yeah
you know and
now that we don't all have the tools and
maybe i made people uncover also my
brother was older and aggressive and he
would be fighting my bro also brothers
getting fights sure my brother beat the
[ __ ] out of me you know like not just
you know like like
jumped on i remember those i was in the
den watching the simpsons i'm sure i
there was some reason that i didn't know
about but just came in and jumped on me
landed his knees on my lap so i couldn't
stand up and start [ __ ] beating me
and i was like
um
great cornbread though yeah
check him out on jeopardy will you
hey mrs glassman i gotta leave
call my mom but yeah people would see
you know i'm either wrestling them or
seeing me getting beat up or what was
the rest where did the wrestling like
wwe f wrestling yeah yeah that kind of
wrestling um and also like i was saying
uh my brother liked to box
so and i i thought my brother was so
cool my brother was good at basketball
brother so funny brother smart
so um not as cool as mine sure
let me call him
i wouldn't answer
he's probably on tv or something he's
probably fighting somebody
um but yeah it was an aggressive house
you know it was an aggressive house
um
kind
okay kind uh but i think the fairest way
to say it is just lacked awareness was
was hyper and if if if the other person
didn't share in the dynamic and some did
you know i i do remember thinking
because my mom said to me it's so nice
that you're friends with such and such
or such and such not like i'm
necessarily doing that a favor but like
she's glad that that is happening yeah
and i always thought that like i'm a
good guy i'm friends with the weird kids
wow and i didn't know i was one of them
until within the past five years
um what happened to five years the
second time you said within the past
five years or what happened in five five
years ago that shut this loose i
this isn't a secret and i'm happy
talking about it i don't love talking
about it too much i talk on the pod and
it is a thing but i was diagnosed with
autism five years ago okay
and
that changed so much for me 100 um
there were so many unrelated things that
that connected in patterns um and i mean
really five five you know i'm in my 30s
when i found out and and just developing
i've told this story on the podcast
before on a podcast i feel like you need
to say that in case people i don't know
but um i'm on the show called undateable
uh
are my boss bill lawrence shout out to
bill owens president's community up here
uh
successful dude uh he has a basketball
game i'm in the game for years um
and he sent me an email uh i there's
been a a year has been going where i'm
like you were in one of those la
basketball how i got so i never was on a
pretty show
bill saw me at the improv
came up to me well he went actually
specifically see brent morning you guys
know brent yes yes very funny comic one
of my best buds uh brent came to see him
i was on the show
he took a liking to us and we after the
show we're talking basketball and i'm
like well this is ironic dude yeah this
is where
my value comes from people like me since
i started playing basketball people only
like me because i'm good at basketball i
get down to the pain i don't leave that
[ __ ] box yeah you got to see what i
could do
turner's got a headband
the game's a great game it's what you
want it's industry it's indoor only they
never have more than 15 guys so you
don't have to wait more than one game so
there's a list of people
and he says there's a list of people i
go why don't you give me your
assistant's phone number email i'll
check in he goes okay
every week for months
finally she's like all right why don't
you get you guys come brent and i came
and i was [ __ ] brent makes fun of it
and it's funny and the way he says it
makes me look a little much but it's
also i'm awesome okay i'm just
you know
i'm i'm aggressive i'm in and it was
great and so was some of some of the
people and i'm in the game bill sends me
an uh brendan email hey i want you to
audition for the show i don't even i
don't have
an agent i have never auditioned for a
show before that was my first job
i'm in this game for years bill's a a
friend you know he's i've known him for
years
and
uh
so cut two years later i've i learned a
little bit about autism and i'm starting
to realize some stuff and like am i
autistic and i'm not gonna get checked
it's like five grand and it's tough to
diagnose an adult uh sometimes it's
depending but like where i met it's
tough gotcha um as a kid it would have
been easier yeah that's all i'm thinking
about is you were come you you went
undiagnosed and were [ __ ] completely
mishandled as a kid and that put all
these feelings in you of feeling like
lost and and and you know feeling like
there's something wrong with you and
this that anything and if they would
have [ __ ]
approached it a little bit different
your whole life would have been
different right
this is really corny uh i'm so grateful
for the way everything went uh-huh i
wouldn't
i'm the comedian i am and i'm i'm really
because of that yeah and of course
and i think i'm really good and i became
good kind of recently it took me a while
to figure out how to be do the craft
it's hard obviously sure but i'm really
grateful for the language of comedy that
i learned which was
you know i never i never knew how people
felt about me but i wasn't aware that i
didn't know i just whatever i'm thinking
you're thinking and i'm i grew up i'm
glad thanks mom and dad i grew up
thinking i'm [ __ ] awesome sure
everyone likes me i'm funny david wants
to come over his mom won't let him you
know so like
i never knew how people felt about me so
i filled in the blame he likes getting
it with a folding chair
when he walks into the house
so i never i never ultimate warrior
oh man i'm going to cry i want to see
this [ __ ] show that's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] ball in my eyes out um
let's talk about dave dave you mean my
best pal dave greatest guy in the world
dave good old friend dave balin yet you
got a wedding coming up you don't get
your strap for cash you got a couple of
bills you got to straighten out you want
to take the bird out to a nice meal not
want to look like a bozo have hair ask
her to put it on her card had to do that
before
i promise she ain't calling back do
yourself a favor get on dave let him
straighten you out a little bit yeah if
you're living paycheck to paycheck or
struggling to make ends meet it can be
really stressful when unexpected
unexpected expenses come up now dave can
help you in a pinch when you really need
it uh dave is a banking app that can
help you get up to 500 instantly with
extra cash
that's more money to fill your tank buy
a wedding gift catch up on bills lay it
all in the jets whatever you want to do
you can finally tackle those expenses go
from bad to worse that have been
stressing you out without any hang-ups
uh there's no interest and no credit
check needed millions of people have
already downloaded the dave app and get
the financial relief they need with
extra cash yeah so if you're in a pinch
you need some extra help download dave
and think of a helping hand from future
you
download the dave app from the app store
right now that's d-a-v-e sign up for an
extra cash account and get up to five
hundred dollars instantly
for terms and conditions go to dave.com
legal instant transfer fees apply
banking provided by evolve member fdic
future you will thank you kip let's talk
about this place display baby yeah what
are you covering up the holes in your
walls with huh regular posters not
spackle like a boozer
get a nice [ __ ] cool metal poster
like this thing here
heavy bike posters we're doing nowadays
that's for dudes who are jacked and cool
and have sex with chicks absolutely
that's what we're doing baby they offer
features officially licensed designs
including star wars netflix star wars
gaming movies comics anime whatever
you're into hey i'm not judging you like
anime get a display of your favorite
anime do yourself a favor it only takes
20 seconds to hang a display no power
tools needed no damages no frustrations
once you mount once you mount one you
can switch over new plate and a flash
easy peasy uh with every one display you
buy display plants a tree look at that
look at that cool stuff for your house
save the environment all in one thing
there you go uh you click the link in
our description to see some of the
favorite displays and save up to 29
other people out there doing 20 15 10
we're doing up to 20 29 get 25 off when
you buy one or two and 29 off when you
buy three or more they're giving away
the store over there do yourself a few
discounts will auto be automatically be
applied to your car when you click the
link or use the code garbage when you
visit diskplate.com that's display
dot com code garbage or click the link
in our show notes do it
bring that back up because i want to
talk to you about something i'm working
on later okay
um
uh
so
so uh
what i was saying is i never knew how
people felt about me but it wasn't like
how do they feel i i it's just like a
subconscious thing
but i always knew when somebody laughed
that in that moment you know we're
connected right yes so it wasn't that
i'm necessarily the funniest it's just i
loved making people laugh and i love
laughing with people i like making him
laugh but if i'm not the one making him
laugh we're laughing we're on the same
page and i knew that right there's a
saying you can't fake that right i mean
you can fake but
it's undeniable yeah i don't think you
can i mean i remember sandler in one of
those roundtable interviews like for ask
or something he was talking about the
hardest thing and i agree with this the
hardest thing to do as an actor is to
fake laughs yeah 100 yeah you know right
yeah you know
um
even if you're not in this business you
could something it feels a little
disingenuous or like for sure
so don't worry about it yeah um
but i learned so much about like
learning how to
if i could say something in a way that
gets a laugh
then it's good
what i didn't know really until five
years ago was how [ __ ] exhausting
that is for everybody and just
needing to get laughs being on all the
time being out all the time and people
always said to me i never know if you're
joking you're serious and
i say this all the time on my podcast
but i never thought and i still don't
think that those two things are mutually
exclusive on both yeah i'm being playful
but if i need something and i'm
uncomfortable or i think i might make
you uncomfortable more realistically
if i could say it in a funny way maybe
it's better maybe you know pick your
battles sure also i was exhausted i
didn't want to always be [ __ ] doing
this i'm [ __ ] drained constantly but
you had to it was in you i it was
i i when i call comedy a language i mean
that quite literally i spoke english as
a second language i spoke comedy comedy
is my language so i only know how to say
hey i have to i have to use your
bathroom i didn't know that sentence i
always knew i gotta go take a big
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know not really but
like you know what i'm saying like
like that's another way to say it
communicated i learned how to talk in
this in the [ __ ] annoying loud
[ __ ] way
and i just thought that's what it was i
just
also i [ __ ] love this game i play you
right now he's all right when people
didn't make me laugh i'm thinking like
what's the point of you i definitely
yeah that's still i might have autism
now that i think about it this guy's
bringing up most of my life like
seinfeld said somebody give me a
basketball sign if you're not going for
a joke what are you doing
um i've i've i remember i said this to
my mom and uh or years ago and it is
something sexual so if it seems weird my
mom i i don't talk about they're on the
phone let's do it live
you're worried about weird now we're
[ __ ] a half hour in what are you
coming i'm thinking that i just feel
like this could be contextualized not
that it's weird but inaccurately like
there's no weird here i don't talk to my
mom about coming too much but i do
remember saying like i had this
awareness and i said to her if somebody
doesn't
make me laugh
teach me something feed me or make me
come what's the point of them
and i don't think if that's selfish i
i've always i always felt like selfish
has bad pr
you need to offer me something and i
need to offer you something or the
relationship doesn't serve a purpose
and i don't need people to feed me not
too many people know how to make me come
autism just joking but you know what i
mean
but your friends if you if they don't
make you laugh
or if they're not super interesting and
could like teach you stuff
no i completely agree yeah i understand
um so in my mind
that's also my value my value was oh i
funny
another value of mine is i'm a great
basketball player and i gotta say
when does this episode come out this
month
this month yeah we'll be out like 48
hours i'll send you a clip we're cut to
it we'll cut to a clip up um
hold on one sec so so i i uh uh
back to the me getting kicked out of
this basketball game i don't know wait
you got kicked out of the basketball
game oh did i have to tell you do you
really want me
i got a million bucks i got a million
nuts we don't have to this guy gave you
a show to so you wouldn't show up to his
game anymore no no no no
and you're charging people in the lane
we'll give you a straight to series deal
just stop showing up
this is years after i'm in the game i've
been in this game for years
years after the game starts i'm on the
on the i'm i'm on the show i mean i'm in
the game then we're on a tv show for
three and a half years okay then the
show gets cancelled i'm still in the
game for another year or so before this
happens where he sends me an email and i
want to preface by saying the email is
going to sound mean and aggressive
it was pure love one of the night it
changed my life for the better and it
was he did something for me that other
people haven't and a lot of people don't
which was he told me something that i
didn't know that benefited me to know
it's just kind of a a more
personal version of hey you got a booger
in your nose sure
right uh he sends this email saying um
which we're big on that
love to tell i don't love to tell
somebody but now 100 percent know that
i'm with somebody
um
so i'm thinking do i have autism for
like a year i'm not maybe
but then within a two week period i got
kicked out of uh of a poker game
and that one it's because they're boring
i'll take responsibility for everything
but they're boring i'm having fun they
didn't want to wrestle
not seriously not one person wanted to
wrestle
so guys i got a pair too someone get on
my shoulder so there i got topher grace
in a headlock all right here we are
mix up that cube would you
man we're having a good time
all right so um but you know i put a pin
in the poker game okay and then but to
the email for the email yeah so i get
kicked out of this basketball hey rick
hey handsome that's what he calls
everybody calls everybody handsome
this is a tough email to send mm-hmm
uh
a couple of the guys in the game don't
like playing when you're here
and
um when i was younger i i've had some
issues and and and i thought [ __ ] these
guys so if you want to say [ __ ] [ __ ] off
you know you have every right to do that
but
i just think this is you lack some
awareness and there's some things that i
don't think you realize about how people
feel about you uh and then you listed
some stuff and some of which made sense
some of which i still disagree with um
but
uh i can't argue and deny and i knew
this then this it was like um
can i have two or three things on the
list
yeah okay um
you you're too aggressive you're yelling
at people you talk a lot of [ __ ] you're
always you're always yelling at stuff
okay
uh
you don't uh
you don't pass the ball enough okay you
don't get back on d so he's just
critiquing again
it wasn't double dribbled in the
championship i didn't want to say
anything it wasn't mostly about my game
it was mostly about my behavior in the
game yeah yeah yeah um which doesn't the
autism creates like a blind side to you
acting like truly it can't be
listen
mate
i'm not this way because of autism i'm
this way because this is this is this is
the way i am however some of the
character traits of autism didn't help
me be aware to make the choice to be
different which i think i would have but
who knows sure right um but it's not an
autistic thing it's it's um the the the
where i could connect the autism to was
um
the reality and what i realized when i
read this email was maybe maybe yes yes
no no all of those things there's a
through line too i had no idea anybody
felt that way or could feel that way
okay and
you know i've
said this as an analogy before but if
someone checks their watch a lot of
times people think maybe they're bored
and want to go i think oh it's and
you'll i'll tell them the time okay so i
didn't know
um
so even if it wasn't true if nobody
wants to play with me that's something
that's something's happening that i'm
doing wrong
um
incidentally and i said we'll put up a
clip uh uh
i uh i was where i wrote this show that
i was pitching with bill okay and uh
this was years ago and i made this
before the email
after the email i got he said so the
email was i'm not going to kick you out
of this game i think you should not show
up for a few weeks okay think about if
you want to come back to the game and
hear some of the things and you know i
love you and it is what it is um
and that really that really um it really
felt bad
i wasn't mad at him it felt really bad
like i've been in this game for years
i'm some of these guys in this game
are been writers on the show i mean i'm
these are my friends you know very much
are they my friends you know and
uh i didn't like that they had to tell
bill and bill had to tell me instead of
telling me i also have i used to think
[ __ ] those guys i'm in the i'm
responsible for my end but also if you
guys told me this i would have been
known if i had a booger in my nose yeah
um i have since learned uh that although
i still agree that that should that is
what you people should do people are
afraid of confrontation not because they
don't want to make the other person feel
bad but that they would feel bad because
they feel bad people people run away
from uncomfort even if it builds
resentment and i think that's
that's a shitty indirect inefficient way
of communicating but i've also learned
that everybody has their own tools and
it's not
their responsibility to communicate the
way i want them to so i've since
dissolved that and and i i take my
responsibility i also have come into
some
i was reeled when i first found out um
i got real excited because like was it
diagnosis yeah okay like so you went and
used i got diagnosed
with five g's it was a different thing
uh it met with it i found this adult
behavior the the the test for ucla is
just for kids or specific more
specifically this was an adult behavior
specialist who deals this is what she
does and met for a while and she gave me
this diagnosis and at first it was like
see
not see that i'm autistic but see like
see rick you're a good guy like you're
not you're not people
you know my intentions were good which
isn't everything but matters and that
was what i was resting on sure and it's
not all that matters at all but like oh
oh oh kid when i was a kid all these
things they connect everything's so much
connected and then i i i started
researching and learning and reading
more about it and it's like oh my gosh
and all these things and there's one
book i forgot what it's called and
people i've talked about my podcast
people message me i feel it's relevant i
want to say uh asperger's from the
inside out it's called it was this guy
who wrote it who wasn't diagnosed until
his kid his kid was so he point being he
was diagnosed as an adult too and all
the feelings of
is this what it is am i and oh and all
like i've all these tools that i built
myself some were very efficient some
inefficient and just from the
perspective of learning as an adult it
was very it was very nice to be like oh
yeah this is i there's a community of
this you know
then as i started wanting to like i
would tell some of my friends um
some would say yeah obviously some say
that's not you're not autistic and i
remember i felt dirty needing to
convince people well you didn't know me
when i was a kid and what and i was like
selling people on a thing that wasn't
meant to be an identity it was just like
pierce is literally giving me a book now
of learning stuff and and i became
depressed too because i started to
realize you know
so this i'll go in and out of the show
that i was writing or am but
it was because if that's the story but
this guy who's who's the funniest best
basketball player in the world everyone
loves him he turns 30 uh and finds out
nobody likes him and it's like that hap
that's
you know
everything is different than what i
thought it was
not that things changed and that's
what's weird the diagnosis didn't change
who i was it just opened up awareness
and things didn't change which means
it's always been this way and i only
remember my memories and what was my
responsibility and why is this and and
then i became so sad and
i don't know when i'm bothering you but
i know that you probably won't tell me
and i might do it at some point so now
i'm walking around like by the way i'm
sorry if i'm
is this okay this is [ __ ] no i'm
saying that stuff i do that stuff oh
okay
but like that was [ __ ] seamless
holy [ __ ] all right we're doing an act
off okay i didn't know that
toby get my skull
hey you gonna rope-a-dope me
i don't like that um
i didn't know so i'm like walking around
i'm walking around i remember i i i i
know it feels like i'm walking around on
um blindfolded on a beach where there's
like a line in the sand and i never know
where the line is and people could move
wherever you want to put your no one
tells you yeah so i don't know
and i'm just so depressed and i don't
know what i'm supposed to be doing
because
i am taking the responsibility
completely on me
because i've bothered people and it took
me a a bit before i started to kind of
come out the other end and realize i am
responsible and i'm not responsible for
you
um and that's where i started develop
tools of of um
i've realized that people
people aren't usually upset annoyed or
disappointed by
i mean relatively in the in the gray
area pocket by
who you are or what you say or what you
do what makes what triggers them or
upsets them or makes them uncomfortable
is when their expectations aren't met
right and we all
a lot of people have subconscious
expectations of what an interaction is
supposed to be based on reputation and
based on their own experiences so when i
come into a comedy podcast i'm expecting
to be silly and blah blah blah if you
guys are not that thing it might be a
little jarring and the jarring is the
issue not who you are
so i found a way to
let people know beforehand my podcast is
called take your shoes off because take
your shoes off is an easy i have ocd
it's an easy one for people that makes
sense but it's also like an ice breaker
sure i also need you to wash your hands
and put your cell phone in the phone
soap and sit on the blanket the pounding
that's a yeah gotcha okay uh i thought
he was trying to big time
so uh if you could if you could frame uh
which is i don't want it to be my
responsibility and but it's it's kind of
a tool of communication if you could
frame people's expectations of you and
or the interaction it'll only be best
sure so
i now when i meet people i'll i'll say
certain things and this is a different
situation because this is play time and
i know it's supposed to be play time so
i don't need to where i think i'm gonna
be the same page with you but when you
meet people
you sometimes have to say hey i'm uh
i get a little silly
if feel free please if it's if you're
never not on board just say rick like
bring it down mm-hmm i have no e it's
true i got no ego attached to this tell
me but i won't know it makes people feel
safe sure to tell me but also oh he's a
lot
i'm expecting that it's okay
and i started to
realize that oh people
other people's expectations of
interactions are not my fault and it
just made me start feeling a little bit
better yeah it's good but i wrote this
thing ultimately i wrote this thing uh
and i i made this web series called the
sixth lead shot of the sex elite on my
youtube and it was great um i was a six
lead on undateable and we made this
little web series um that ended up being
on hulu for a little bit in nbc.com and
it won awards and i say this
bragging because it felt really good of
course i made this thing about i mean
that's a pretty not to cut you off
that's a pretty [ __ ] long pretty
[ __ ] tough journey and to see some
kind of [ __ ]
you know
accolades from that that's
understandable yeah because also i was
playing a it's very curb inspired it's a
bad curb your enthusiasm but i was
playing a heightened version of myself
of now seeing how people saw me and now
i get to do that for entertainment i get
to be that thing contextualized sure um
and i got to do on the warner brothers
lot we got to shut down one of the
streets i had extras uh costumes crafty
security i'm directing this thing it was
very
awesome and uh bill saw it and liked it
and wanted me to make more and he now
started to say oh rick's you know i
don't think i was too good on that
that's that sitcom but look oh rick's
funny like rick is a he found a thing
and this is after the email this is
after all this stuff this is before the
email okay this is bill has now seen me
this thing i also think the way that
bill was able to communicate with me i
think that was uh and um i don't want to
put words in his mouth i'll tell you how
i felt i felt like like bill thought it
was funny put me on the show i was
whatever on the show he thought i had
potential but i wasn't doing it there
were some issues on the show too that i
didn't realize were happening i always
wore headphones people thought i didn't
want to talk or i was i was being
disrespectful but i owe just things i
didn't know and i don't think i had the
best reputation on that set for the
first year and a half
um and then bill saw me do that and then
he started like
and you didn't know any of this stuff
yet you weren't diagnosed you didn't i
didn't wasn't diagnosed um yeah what the
[ __ ] i didn't know this stuff um not to
say that people didn't say things but it
didn't register to me i got you
um
but then the email thing happened and
uh
a year goes by i've since been diagnosed
i'm already back in the game uh bill was
really sweet too i had shoulder surgery
right after he kicked me out so i didn't
come back for like months and months so
when i came back bill said if if if i'm
bill and you're me okay and all the
other guys are shooting around over here
bill made a point to stand over here so
other people here um how's your shoulder
surgery i know that's why you were gone
for a while like trying to not let that
throw me you know class move and i said
i'm feeling better but i also know that
a lot of guys here don't like playing
with me
cause i didn't
[ __ ] you guys he's like what the [ __ ]
i said you were getting your ears
pierced what are you doing
i [ __ ] love it
and what did they say nobody said
anything
some of the guys didn't know that
yeah some of the guys didn't know why i
was kicked out didn't know i was kicked
out some of them obviously [ __ ] them but
also
i in my head
the point of playing basketball is to
win that's where my value is that's why
we're here nobody wants to lose and sit
a game so [ __ ] win
while other people are there to have a
good time actually playing your friends
yeah maybe pull it back a little bit on
a saturday but i like the [ __ ] hustle
i like the driving yeah there's
something that changed when you went
back were you like okay i can now see
this more socially it made me think of
like when i went back to school he
wouldn't even harder in ninth grade
he's running
suicide man this guy's all right man i'm
[ __ ] telling you packing guys in the
paint nice [ __ ] email
um check the ball you just keep fighting
it yeah check the ball check the ball
i'm open i'm just a fast break i refuse
to shoot a layup you want me to shoot
i'm sorry you don't want to win
[ __ ] cowards
um
hey i know you're a soldier surgery yeah
and everybody hates me
um when i made the sixth lead uh and
when i was editing it i love it i'm
proud of it i i love people seeing it i
think it's it's done it's gotten me jobs
it shows people what i'm able to do it's
my voice i'm very happy with it while
i'm editing it like anybody else who
does stuff i'm seeing some stuff i could
have done different if i make more
here's what i would do
and i remember thinking like i like this
process
so a year ago or so goes and i have this
idea for this show based around this
thing and i film uh i film a short not
meant to show anywhere but basically
before i write this thing let me film it
edit it
for the writing process
um and it was really funny i never but
i made it um joel mchale plays bill
lawrence uh the script was uh written
around the email that bill sent me so it
was really like taking some ownership
and power and creative artistic like
choices through this thing that was
ultimately very beneficial for me but
like a hard thing and to mabel make it
funny um
and we were doing and then bill and i
and and uh another uh producer shout out
john stern from futon stupid gesture we
were out going out to pitch this thing i
was gonna say
this was all
you got cast in that after all this
awakening right no that was before
because it seems like
you fit in like
you fit more into that
now
from what you're telling me does that if
you haven't seen the movie it's awesome
it's great it's a story of the net
origins but do you see what i'm saying
like no
i fit so that character yeah maybe yeah
listen also it's not like i'm diagnosed
and all of a sudden like i stopped
punching people and you know like i was
i'm still
no that's what i'm saying
no like i'm still like you know at this
point i have i have friends i'm not like
the worst guy i'm not horribly annoying
i'm just a lot sure and you know
just you know just like any other
annoying guy who doesn't you know
it wasn't um it wasn't like i couldn't
do stuff
um so when i booked that it was
unrelated
uh but
but the guy i met from it um bill and i
were going out to pitch this show okay
right when i booked uh as we see at that
amazon show
so i couldn't do my show anymore so i
didn't finish it um i didn't finish uh
that short because it was only for me
anyway
years go by i'm watching the footage
with um
john michael who edits my podcast with
me and i'm like this is really funny i
want to do something with this but there
was no ending so i filmed an ending last
month in literally over three years um
and i'm putting it out august 29th so
that's when i'm like we'll show a sizzle
clip i was kind of joking but i'll send
it to you um but i made this gonna send
you 15 videos uh yeah you know what have
this podcast be like bts some of the
stuff i want to send you yeah
i cannot overemphasize the fact that i
do not know how to add it all right
august 29th check out my channel that
stuff's plugged in
um but
i i i've really i've really like uh it's
been a really nice way of self
acceptance of like
not only growing and learning um
becoming more aware and learning more
tools of communication but also to then
like
use this stuff that that could be
embarrassing or shameful which isn't
maybe i'm wrong but it isn't uh as
like character stuff yeah yeah of course
no
um shame kind of gets in the way of of
acceptance and like
to be embarrassed about something makes
sense and i'm nervous and embarrassed
about a lot of stuff but to feel shame
about who i was as opposed to gratitude
for getting it here just makes me not be
able to accept the thing and as corny as
this is self-acceptance has changed my
life
um it's made me
uh happy
er
but it also has made me not try and sell
you who i am like this i am a lot
you know i zig when i'm supposed to zag
no it's okay
but the stuff that you said before we
started about how i'm my podcast is
stupid and i meant that
i'm going to accept myself as well we
did call rick's mom before the podcast
and say we cannot come over and hang out
we did say that
we came i went over he put me in a full
nelson we did cancel the sleepover which
we apologize we'll make it up next week
but i have now started putting people in
half nelson's
i've made a compromise i've toned it
down
i do four stunners a month that's it i
do think uh now knowing that i didn't
know i and i always knew you had a
different take on i mean i didn't you
know we didn't know each other well or
at all before this i always knew you had
a very different take on comedy it
wasn't
dcoc what's that dtoc dtoc a different
take on comedy um is that a one-time
acronym ota whoa w hit me hm that's
pretty good right-handed yikes are you
good at them
what the [ __ ] i get left yeah i had a
right hand i need the right i have a
thing oh okay thanks he just went over
it what are you doing i didn't know what
the [ __ ] you two were doing just like
tas one-time acronyms but if i'm missing
a high five i want in
m-a-h-f-i-w-i
jesus i'm not that good
maybe i'm not autistic i don't know
what's 16 times nine w-s-t-t
did he just do that yeah he did jesus
christ yes it was 16 by nine that he hit
the acronym instantly what is it 145
wild no but he did an acronym for what i
asked him
dude it's moving too quick mix up the
cubes i had a couple of cocktails last
night everybody's slowly being serious
yeah i haven't done it in a while no
i've actually never done it but you've
never done it i just i can't imagine
they're that hard
that's good i've never done i always
cheated isn't it it's always like it's
always like 32 moves from being solved
at any given point i don't know dude
i really just want i don't know how to i
want to just play with it but keep
talking piece of [ __ ]
i feel like you have your own cameras in
here
i [ __ ] love it man i [ __ ] love it
i'm never gonna get him out of this
thing
jesus christ
dude that is a [ __ ] wild [ __ ] tale
man that is something else thanks man
good to be here
yeah he just seemed thrilled
um i'll play this in a little bit yeah
sure
uh no it's good to be back
um
what else
what else
did you go to college
what
yeah rikers
kent state
okay oh yeah see i told you guys i told
you they would be okay with kent state
what could i have said where you guys
would have not said okay
oh yeah yeah yeah i've heard of it i
mean i don't know right right right
right
oh my god uh
do you take the sats
a cts probably uh i took an sat i don't
remember i just went to kent because my
brother went to can i'm like i'll go
there graduated
okay degree and what marketing with uh
uh i was also doing theater but i was
able to graduate a half a semester
earlier which is not early four and a
half instead of five okay um
two uh uh so i just didn't finish
theater because i didn't i didn't take
that like yeah in the real world yeah
i'm working stiff all right that was
unfucking believable okay yeah that's
okay that was fantastic let's get into
some [ __ ] some some garbage cues here
you want to go back a little bit your
parents live in the same house that you
grew up in yeah they do
um was it a street a boulevard an avenue
lane an oval
oval so it was like you mean a
cul-de-sac
so the address would be like stop with
the rubik's cube yeah
now i can feel i'm drawing my line in
the sand
put the [ __ ] rubik's cube down get
the [ __ ] blue tape let's go
getting this kid organized here
it was an oval
this keeps going but your mom's gonna be
in here call me hitler in 20 minutes
all right what was the name of the
grocery show that you went to as a kid
doesn't matter dude
[ __ ] dick
give me it give me the rubik's cube stop
it uh we really want another grocery
store i feel like yeah what do you mean
this is the show
all right heinen sounds pretty classy
where do you shop now
you got a couple of bucks now you're
doing all right i'm an air one guy air
one not that's that one that everybody
talks about how crazy expensive it is
it's not like rice or an avocado it is
it's the writer for grocery stores
really yeah okay i go to whole foods
often kelsey
to see the common folk well i i love uh
i love the prepared foods uh i'm gluten
free okay um no offense and i uh they
have a lot of stuff on their hot bars
organic gluten free i like it
and you you you own a place out in l.a
say again you own a place you own such
an app
i knew i shouldn't have [ __ ] gave it
to you i haven't done it in a while was
the name of the pizza place and chinese
place in your hometown gracies pizza
very good diner drivings and dives
worthy whoa
from the king how come i didn't get that
when i said kent state
uh because guy fieri wasn't there what
the [ __ ] i don't know what to tell you
man
get some [ __ ] bleach and flame out
the [ __ ] uh 57 chevy
walk with wing was the chinese place
that was the spot um however
um that went away and now it's hawa
okay yeah
all right when was the last time you
were on a boat and where was it
[ __ ] dude a long time ago in a galaxy
uh so i'm really like uh upset that i'm
not able to figure out how to do this
while i'm chatting with you um
i said i was on a boat i don't know [ __ ]
it next okay
water ski to camp jew camp
what was the name of the what was the
name of the jewish camp i'm a kauffman
camp what do you know
you want to do your research this guy
i'm a kaufman camp you idiot oh man
you have a car i do what are you
whipping around in uh a uh hybrid
electric audi q5 audi oh yeah okay owned
or leased least dude okay always a lease
yeah i'm a season yeah at least that's
pretty good ever by the floor model of
an appliance or a tv no okay my brother
once got me true lies on dvd and it was
used and i don't keep it with my other
ones
i totally get that though
that's nothing has ever rang so true to
me
what's your mom's best friend's first
name
uh
it's none of my business to say okay
i'll say it lolly lolly okay i like a
lolly that's pretty good
that's pretty good will you
wash your hands at the res
yeah i wash my hands before i pee
really yeah so if i'm gonna eat here as
well sometimes listen you're at a
restaurant
lemons and limes on lemons or limes on
the table will you wash your hands with
them at the table no
okay i will uh order before i wash my
hands though because i've touched the
menu
okay
okay any pets growing up oh yeah
lay it on me there i'm a cat boy a cat
boy i'm a cowboy just one cat two cats
multiple how are we talking about here i
mean we got hurt
bleep all of them i'm not kidding i know
you don't edit bleep all those i've
never said my cats names and i'm not
joking bleep their names a lot of them i
don't want to tell them are you killing
anybody will you bleep these names yeah
thank you i'm an incredible editor by
the way
it was all a ruse
sounds like it was a lie do you know the
difference between a ruse and a lie
a ruse is an elaborate lie
my mistake
and look i don't know what i've done not
yet not yet jesus
and you said that's just like a sizzle
reel for him he's doing him he's got his
basketball tongues going he's got a
rubik's cube yeah i mean
now we try to ask him questions and he
clams up and you stepped on my did you
kill any of the pets line um hershey
squirshy you could say that name we
closed the garage in him thanks dad it
was an accident
he was a he was this is before censors
this is pre-coveted and uh that was a
couple houses down
how many car garage did you have growing
up two two car could you fit two cars in
there was it filled with stuff you fit
two cars in there although there's three
now because um when i went to college my
gran my my my mom's parents who lived in
california the last few years they were
alive they sold their place and moved in
with us so we put a little we used that
money we put a little uh addition under
the home okay okay give them like their
own little living area and then another
small part of the garage okay write that
down i'm gonna write that down
right next to lolly
putting it down there and killed cat
got that on there
sorry please what did you do job wise
when you were a kid did you work did you
work in a workers permit when i was 13
worked at mcdonald's worked for eight
months made maybe 600 dollars kept going
home i was too hot
hated it i go home okay you would ask to
leave i would have to leave constantly
i'd also ask people to do the coffee
because it made me too hot
all right
now but then i worked at best buy
i would leave it and it was too cold
i worked in the computer department did
a good job sold a lot of computers got
big into computers for a while i sold so
many computers that they let me uh they
gave me some free cds i got a hardball
cd
uh and then another cd
so what's hardball what i don't know
what that is the storm is over storm is
overnight
no shout out to shane falco
ziggy zaki zigizaki
i have that soundtrack too
the man show
what is it from the man show i know that
from the replacements
oh yeah that's right irish kicker yeah
probably
irish or kicker you can't put them
together
at your place now
do you get dressed in front of the dryer
no no
is that because you keep your clothes in
the dryer yeah that would be a trashy
thing you know i don't do that if you
leave your [ __ ] in the dryer no no i
also when i take it out i don't even i
don't throw it in a drawer i fold
everything i put the socks together i do
the the ocd uh she's having a nice
closet i don't think that's ocd you keep
everything nice and neat though at the
house yeah shorts color coordinated
shorts are colored shirts shirts colored
follow cds so i open your closet
you won't open my closet
i want to be hiding if you ever come to
my podcast you're not even upstairs
doing this one in the third garage
just so we're clear that's not a you
thing i just don't want people up there
okay well i was gonna ask you that it's
with your ocd does somebody like me
skeeve you out no no
hang around a little i'm pretty gross
yeah
you don't want to wash your hands after
you touch that rubik's cube um
hmm if i went to your house right now
and asked for a water what would you
give me i'd ask you colder room temp my
friend whoa and then what would that be
a bottle or do you have like a would you
like room temper cold
uh
let's go room temp i'll i got a berkey
i'll throw it in the glass for you
what's a berkey it's a nice water filter
really on the counter on the counter oh
yeah and then what about cold uh it
depends if i have bottles i often have
bottles sparkling or still if not then
i'll throw in some ice cubes and i'll
let you know that the ice cube tray
never touches the counter unless i wash
it after it's very clean put the nice
filtered water in there if i'm going to
take the ice out i'll ask you but i'll
tell you i already washed my hands
man this is a guy i want to live with uh
yeah a berkey is sick i just looked it
up it's like four hundo and it looks
like something you'd have out at brunch
to like that would have like lemons in
it when you're serving fresh water out
of it sick
all right okay is there baking soda in
your fridge yeah
in your freezer no
um if you
were preparing pasta at your house when
on a tuesday i'm just saying when i'm
preparing pasta yes when you're
preparing pasta easier i apologize
gotcha when you're preparing pasta at
your house when am i doing it tuesday 5
p.m
cloudy outside right well i'm not making
pasta on a nice day
i want to be walking outside not car
bevvy
that was too quick for me to laugh
in business
code over here
do you cook the whole box of pasta in
the whole jar of sauce or will you will
you half it and put it back in the
fridge or the
you call it a box of pasta is already
i'm out
no i get i i'm not making my own noodles
but i buy fresh noodles uh gluten-free
okay uh how'd you do that
i've seen a menu before and um but yeah
but that would be asterick gf
sure i uh it's got more cold i'm more
casual with it all right a lot of garlic
a lot of garlic uh one whole onion if
not two saute that up for a while so
you're not making the sauce you're not
doing jarred sauce no i'm jar sauce but
i'm doctoring but the question is will
you will you do you use the entire jar
of sauce or will you put it half use jar
sauce back in the fridge uh i will i've
done both okay it depends on how much
i'm making and what's doing because some
sometimes with the pasta when you get
fresh it's not as much as a
box yeah um but but a lot of times i
like to make food that i think will last
me two three days so i don't have to
keep making it okay but then you just
eat it that day gotcha so you figure out
what am i gonna do am i gonna be home
how much am i trying to make i'll throw
it in the fridge but you know i try to
use that sauce within a week okay all
right that's pretty good it's pretty
pretty pretty good have you been kicked
out of a restaurant
asked to leave no i've been kicked out
of a poker game and basketball game in a
school though
i've been kicked out of stuff only by my
friends why'd you get kicked out of the
poker game because they were boring
we're just we're sitting around these
are these are boring people okay and
also i know some of some of them i'm
still friendly with and uh maybe watch
and and i have to acknowledge that
i'm not talking about everybody but also
you know you know your poker game is
boring as [ __ ] and you guys are dry as
[ __ ] and i'm in there and i'm being
silly sometimes and they're taking like
all through the table
they're just like like uh you know did
you golf like yeah no i went golf and i
wasn't sure you know i wasn't sure if i
would want to go um but i ended up doing
it and you know i i decided to just do
nine instead of eight and i'm like oh
okay i'm not you know have your
conversations but i'm not engaged so and
then talk and
then you're you know you're thinking and
i'm just like joking around like
like if i want you to stay and i'll be
like ah you should fold
you're gonna fall in a little patch
oh hold on real quick also i just want
to say real quick i'm not sure are you a
little [ __ ] me yeah are you a little
[ __ ] sometimes yeah you're a little
[ __ ] sometimes yeah why don't you play
don't be a [ __ ] being silly
all right i'm on their side yeah they're
[ __ ]
you know i'm every now and then in a
hand like that's a device did you have a
pizza cutter in your house growing up
like the wheel one yeah the uh the
restaurant would cut it for him i don't
we didn't make pizzas never had pizza at
the house yeah but we would order a
pizza and you're not cutting that's
already pre-cut fair enough yeah wow
take it easy now
what's the problem
hold on one sec what's the problem
did i say something wrong we could do it
again or do you wanna hey don't make me
send you an email
all right
there's a lot of nice people around here
uh
will you push a button at a red light
i have to yeah i don't love it okay
you don't like to do it for
you don't want to touch it
no do you no right but you have to do it
right well you do with the hand or elbow
or like yeah do you have a spot
does that you think is like impervious
to germs
you'll instead of sacrificing a a hand
or a finger uh i used to but the reality
is
you put it on you touch it with an elbow
or a sleeve then that's dirty man we are
the same person and and sometimes
sometimes you'll go home and you'll be
like i don't want to touch my faces i'll
use this but that's the thing you're
using so what i've had to do is just
accept i'm going to get it on me a lot
has changed a lot has changed recently
for me after cove video it got bad i
started doing stand up again touching
microphones i'm like just get i'm gonna
just [ __ ] let me touch the thing
whatever man
give it to me
you know sometimes i feel like you're
that way too uh yeah i have a very ocd
germs is a very big pre-cover too right
and now i think uh
some autism oh yeah covered was like my
super bowl that was like here i was like
yeah okay everybody has to live like i
live like i felt that way it's like
everyone's before i'm like this is what
it's always been dude i'm wiping down
groceries that's all i ever wanted to do
and not be a wacko will you eat in your
room
yeah yeah really yeah well uh i have a
tray
i have trays in the room no but i'll
bring if i want to eat in the room i'll
make a decision like
i'm gonna
uh
i'm gonna frost myself i'm gonna take
i'm gonna eat i'll be fine i'll have a
napkin i'll have a tray
okay yeah and then how long does that
tray live in the room after you're done
eating i don't i put well it's not gonna
stay there overnight i mean maybe if i'm
in the middle of a movie and i'm
watching something in bed i'll put the
tray on the floor but i always always
even if it's downstairs i don't i don't
i don't like waking up in the morning
and seeing dirty clothes dirty dishes
i don't think that's an ocd thing i just
i know that i don't like that because it
maybe i don't know yeah what if uh say
you're cooking and uh you know you're
making your your fresh pasta and a
noodle falls on the a piece of
noodle falls on the ground will you pick
it up and eat it or is that a go in the
trash um if uh noodle poly will be on
the trash if i'm making a veggie
and my floors have been cleaned recently
it's a game time decision and it's early
in the saute phase i have been known to
put it back in the pan it'll heat up
yeah um but not if i'm cooking for
somebody else
that's so specific man it's so [ __ ]
funny
early in the saute game
how's the bathroom nice and clean yeah
body wash bar what are you doing
body wash body wash i found the ones
that are okay i don't know what they are
i ask my now ex but still friend uh she
told me about all the things i'm
supposed to buy that are the good ones
the healthier ones yeah gotcha yeah i
like um i use a bar sometimes i'm not
against a bar i don't prefer a bar
um
yeah shower curtain or sliding glass
unfortunately curtain curtain okay hmm
all right take your shoes off on a plane
i do now you know what i do i go
enjoy yourself rick i don't like taking
my shoes on a plane because then i'm
putting those socks back in the shoe so
what i used to do is if i needed to take
my shoes off i would then rest my heel
in the hole of the shoe
okay so my sock wouldn't touch the
ground and i've started letting my sock
touch the ground but when i come home
i'll take the sock off when i walk in
huh
by that logic wouldn't the sock get
dirty from the outside of the shoe no
because the sock is in the inside
the my heel goes where the heel is
gotcha and then the top of my shoe at
the top of my my sock is touching the
outside top of the shoe which isn't the
best but that that that was okay for me
you know we make them up we make up our
rules 100 and that one was okay but now
i'll put i'll put it down
but also it depends where you ever you
ever take a shower in a hotel and do you
put your feet on the shower or do you go
heel and toe
i'm all in waiting
toe on the in the show yeah are you
worried i used to not in a public shower
i know exactly what you're talking about
yeah you you would stay on your heel i
don't want the i want as little of my
foot touching that shower as possible so
you you point your toes and prop your
the middle of your like this here's your
foot oh no like almost like tippy toes
that's not a tippy toe and heel yeah
yeah like a trotter like a horse but
then sometimes you're like i'm [ __ ]
gonna touch i'm just standing in it
sometimes i'll be standing in it and not
realize it
and then i'll be like oh
i feel like the best way to explain it
is like
you're both meat eaters
are you totally fine with it or have you
ever considered not eating meat
sometimes i'm fine with it so i'm in the
middle and i just sometimes don't want
to
one because i follow a lot of animals
and i i love animals and i think i mean
i just it doesn't make sense and also
sometimes it just grosses me out sure
but i'll be sometimes eating meat and
then all of a sudden i'll be like what
the [ __ ] am i doing yeah it gets in your
head sometimes yeah so that'd be like
that in the shower sometimes i'll be
like oh
and i'm washing my foot feet again
do you sleep with your socks on
um i probably have fallen asleep with my
socks on but no
how often do you wash in the sheets in
the room
surprisingly not often enough but i
don't do outside clothes in my bed me
too i don't get in my bed dirty okay but
i go oftentimes a month before washing
do you shower before you go to bed every
night if i did something that day
but i i probably shower four times a
week okay i don't shower every day i
also don't leave my house so often okay
um
if i if i go someplace that is dirty to
me whatever that might be if i'm at a
restaurant that feels dirty if i if i'm
uh if i go to a gym or i do anything
where i'm sweating um physical therapy
if i'm laying on a bench or something
uh i'll shower okay
all right
uh if you're eating if you're having a
big dinner or like a fancy dinner then
i'll show you yes will you uh will you
go the whole day without eating or eat
less in anticipation of the big meal
game time it depends how you feel i mean
my pooping situation at the moment is
nothing to write home about so i would
have to consider that like this morning
i've been limiting my gluten but like
i'm on vacation and i want to have some
stuff and i wanted to get a belgian
waffle this morning but i'm like i'm
gonna want a pastrami sandwich tonight
and i parented myself someone i'm like
rick pick one of them
okay um
so i decided to get the pastrami
sandwich so i didn't have the waffle
today but that's more about like
the way i feel my joints kind of swell
up when i gluten in a roundabout way
that answers this question the trashy
thing would be if they were if somebody
was going out to a big meal they
wouldn't eat all day i'm not eating all
day i can't wait to get there i want to
be starving is that trashy yes what yes
very yes you're parenting yourself which
is very classy we gotta wrap up here but
in a one or two left anyone in your
family have a standalone hot tub
just a hot tub in the backyard no
however my parents shower um does have
jets in it the jacuzzi pretty nice
parents do well
well when we were using the restaurant
busy was upper middle class uh then we
moved our way down to middle okay
[ __ ] gross
you got the jets in the shower though
that was that from and they got the
montagues in the bath
i got that reference west side story
okay
fair enough what's the mayo situation
and uh
romeo and juliet yeah what's the
difference right um
yeah i never thought about that really
new york city
that's the difference
what's the mayo situation not gonna do
it although every now and then in a tuna
fish sandwich sure but i recently
discovered i haven't done it but
somebody told me about instead of using
mayo try making tuna fish with hummus
into trying that yeah that's not a bad
idea no in fact
a good idea a little bit um anybody in
your family ever claimed to have seen a
ufo no
that that's that leads to trash
it's not the classiest people are
claiming to go that way you know what i
mean uh have you ever had a subscription
to maxum magazines yeah and stuff
whoa i do for an fhm kind of guy
you and your acronyms i still have them
at home i still have all the the the the
maxims at home because i used to i never
read them i just loved the cover so you
would look at them yeah almost like like
trading cards or comics or something
it's just like wow this is beautiful
yeah yeah it was good times i just
talked about this on on a podcast but i
my mom had whatever i'm not gonna get
into it okay it's about masturbating and
a lamination machine yeah we'll say that
for episode two
all right listen this is what i think
and i'm just shooting from the hip here
i think you've never solved the rubik's
cube yeah you're not gonna get the cube
you got close and then you went off the
rails yeah i haven't done it and i've
never done it could you you never know i
haven't done in a very long time i used
to do it all the time i was able to go i
i give it let me play with it for a day
i'll be good but i used to be able to do
it like hey oh i thought you were asking
tomorrow that for a day no i'm saying
like if i so if i play with this for a
day i bet you once it's off i'll maybe
if i could count the trip i used to be
able to do it under a minute i was like
i thought i haven't done in a while but
i wanted to that's pretty cool i used to
they used to frustrate the [ __ ] out of
me they're inside they're unsolvable to
me i would never be able to do it i'm
going to say this i don't know how
what you guys are thinking this like i
said i'm sure yeah he's classy yeah it's
class he's class thank you i mean he's
got moldy i i asked him what what kind
of water he would give me he said what
temperature do you want he took a temp
on the water like he's a michelin star
chef over here
yeah i appreciate it it's all class baby
come on you [ __ ]
you're not gonna get it
uh you know it's that kind of attitude
that uh really is called
i'm not gonna win any any saturday games
with that kind of attitude shifting
all right
ladies and gentlemen
what an exciting
interesting episode
with mr rick glassman
anything you want the folks out there to
know that you have gone away
plug your pod any dates any anything
it's got a rubik's cube tournament next
week i'm boring am i going to lose for
sure
oh my god
we're getting there no you're not you're
getting [ __ ] further away it's like
me trying to take my wife's bra off i
can't say that anymore
go ahead focus for a solid two minutes
you want you want to do it go ahead
how are you
i'm great
yeah i i i have to i don't know the last
hour sometimes i thought you loved me
then i thought you hated me
is any of that for real a little bit
yeah tell me tell me i concur
no no tell me tell me tell them
like let me put this down
this is deleted scene wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait because of what
what made you think that
i'm here playing i thought we're
laughing and having a great deal 100
percent yes rick of course of course
what happened whole time
tell me what it is because i love you
guys i'm having such a good time
having such a good time with you for
real i thought i pissed you off once or
twice that's all just when i'm okay when
i said kent but other than that
no not at all i'm i'm having such a
great time with you guys i also felt
really nice because i thought maybe i
was being a little boring just telling
you some stories what are you crazy
that's really kind of gripping no of
course and uh
to our point i think one like i said we
don't know you very well so it's like
when you come in we turn the thing on we
have to
learn you learn your rhythm learn your
speech your story like yeah so it's just
we're just figuring you out i mean we've
only been we've only i've only known you
for like an hour and eight minutes i
love you yeah you're fantastic that's
why i said it because
i want you to love me
i i really do i really like
i i this was this is great this was
fantastic i had a [ __ ] fantastic yeah
it was great fantastic well that's rick
catch me at the funny hut um
the uh
the appreciation of
of of an arc of completion of
a of a dismount
is actually quite disa i'm disappointed
that i that i can't do this we get that
i get that but i also want to say so we
cut to him dunking right now
i'll be all right
it's a lot of
i don't want to say pressure because i
don't feel it but there is a lot of
expectation on me from my audience that
everybody in the industry thinks i'm
perfect
and i just wanted this is just nice to
let people know look at even rick
sometimes he's a human yeah yeah yeah
you're like us no no
he's got fresh pasta what are you
talking about
um no but all jokes aside uh uh i gotta
say that now is under the cards
no we have a good time
all right uh if you guys watch the last
eight minutes of this first you probably
won't watch the episode
if you're like me and fast forward to
the end to watch from the middle through
um but uh thank you guys for having me
buddy whenever i'm back here with my
equipment and or you guys are in la of
course um i would love to make you some
recommendations of
restaurants uh yeah you'll come on and
um so there's no so there's no no
confusion i love you guys i appreciate
you guys
really nice thank you of course we love
you what do you got for him uh guys we
just had another philly show first one
sold out get those tickets boston's
gonna sell out providences are going to
sell out seattle sold out portland i
think is going to sell get those [ __ ]
tickets now come see us gang this was a
wild one rick
you're awesome man
let's end it the way we always do eight
seven
six five
we'll see you next week from the
hardball soundtrack